bienvenido a la presentación de
conversión de unidades déjame empezar
con este problema si te dijera que he
viajado punto 0 5 km punto 0 5
kilómetros km entonces cuántos
centímetros cuántos centímetros he
viajado centímetros
entonces lo que el problema nos pide es
convertir kilómetros a centímetros pero
antes de empezar con las cuentas déjame
platicar un poco acerca de estos
prefijos y lo hice en ti y otros más que
nos sirven para resolver este tipo de
problemas de hecho déjame hacer una
tabla por acá que es muy útil aprenderse
para hacer estos problemas rápidamente
entonces la tabla dice así cuando
tenemos el prefijo kilo estamos hablando
de mil de mil de esas cosas por ejemplo
un kilómetro son 1000 metros cuando
tenemos el prefijo esta recta entonces
tenemos 100 a lo mejor lo has escuchado
en hectárea con de acá con de acá
tenemos 10 10 de alguna cosa por ejemplo
en década tenemos 10 años si no tenemos
prefijo siempre fijo prefijo entonces
sólo tenemos una de esas unidades y
luego vienen prefijos para cosas más
pequeñas por ejemplo de si de si es una
décima parte una décima parte por
ejemplo un decímetro es una décima parte
de un metro que también se puede
escribir con
0.1 sentí sentí se refiere a una
centésima parte una centésima parte o
bien podemos ponerla como 0.01 y
finalmente mil y mil y se refiere a una
milésima parte a uno entre mil o bien
0.001 de la unidad que estemos hablando
vale bueno entonces con esta tabla vamos
a resolver el problema tenemos que pasar
de kilómetros a centímetros pero déjame
hacerlo en dos pasos vamos a pasar de
kilómetros a metros y después de metros
vamos a pasar a centímetros va entonces
déjame empezar con esta primer parte de
pasar de kilómetros a metros déjame
poner aquí los puntos 0 5 kilómetros lo
voy a abreviar así kilómetros y lo que
queremos obtener al final son metros
metros entonces cómo le hacemos pues
tenemos que multiplicar estos puntos 60
50 kilómetros por una tasa de conversión
que nos deje metros así que la tasa de
conversión arriba debe de tener metros
km
metros y kilómetros están relacionados
por este mil como sabemos si tenemos que
multiplicar por mil o dividir entre mil
hay dos formas de pensarlo una es
simplemente darse cuenta que mil metros
mil metros es un kilómetro entonces esto
hace que esta expresión sea un 1 y por
lo tanto no se modifique y pasemos a
metros pero otra forma de pensarlo es
qué kilómetros es una unidad más grande
que metros así que al pasar kilómetros a
metros deberíamos obtener más de punto 0
5 vale entonces como debemos tener más
de punto 0 5
hay que multiplicar por mil bueno aquí
kilómetros lo podemos cancelar con con
kilómetros justo así funcionan las
unidades como si fueran números en este
sentido y ahora podemos multiplicar mil
por punto cero cinco mil por punto cero
550 y de esta forma nos quedan 50 metros
muy bien ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
pasar de metros a centímetros misma idea
tenemos que multiplicar aquí por una
tasa de conversión déjame cambiar de
color para que no sea tan monótono
entonces ahora queremos que arriba nos
queden centímetros y que abajo nos
queden metros como lo hacemos para ver
si multiplicamos o dividimos entre 100
pues bueno centímetros es una unidad más
pequeña que metros así que debemos tener
más centímetros que metros nos debe de
quedar algo mayor que 50 así que hay que
multiplicar por ciento otra forma de
pensarlo es que es justo este cien hace
que esta expresión sea un 1 y que
entonces no no se modifique la expresión
pero que nos la cambie a centímetros
vamos a hacer las cuentas aquí metros se
cancela con metros 100 por 50 es cinco
mil cinco mil y finalmente nos queda
centímetros entonces lo único que
estamos haciendo es ver el prefijo a que
corresponde aquí kilo 9000 sentí fue de
1 entre 100 multiplicamos por una tasa
de conversión adecuada y con eso ya
podemos obtener las unidades que
queremos y para saber si multiplicamos o
dividimos por el número podemos
verificarlo pensando en cuál unidad es
más grande o más pequeña
vamos a resolver otro problema y la idea
siempre va a ser intentar visualizar si
queremos más o menos de las unidades
vale entonces ahora vamos a poner este
otro problema en color verde para
cambiarle un poco a los colores entonces
dice que queremos convertir 422
decigramos designamos esta es una unidad
de masa decigramos y estos los queremos
convertir en miligramos entonces
queremos ver cuántos miligramos
miligramos
son vale bueno a ver designamos vamos a
sacar la tabla decigramos es una décima
parte de un gramo lo voy a poner por acá
una décima parte de un gramo gramo y
miligramos es una milésima parte de un
gramo una milésima parte de un gramo
entonces si te das cuenta 100 miligramos
es lo mismo que un decigramos déjame
apuntarlo aquí abajo un decir gramo
es lo mismo que 100 100 miligramos
miligramos entonces ahora ya tenemos una
forma de convertir de desi gramos a
miligramos vale entonces para resolver
este problema pues pues podemos seguir
dos caminos uno es el que hicimos acá
arriba que es pasar a la unidad que no
tiene prefijo aquí sería pasar a gramos
y luego a miligramos pero una segunda
forma que es la que vamos a hacer
ahorita es utilizar esta tasa de
conversión que acabamos de descubrir
vale entonces vamos a utilizar esta tasa
directamente ni tenemos 422 de si gramos
422 de si gramos y queremos pasar a
miligramos cómo le hacemos dividimos
entre de si gramos multiplicamos por
miligramos estas son las abreviaciones y
bueno aquí hay un 100 lo ponemos arriba
o abajo bueno pues lo tenemos que poner
arriba para que esta expresión sea un 1
y no se modifique o bien también podemos
pensar que un miligramo es más pequeño y
por tanto queremos que nos quede más así
que hay que multiplicar por 100 y bueno
realizando las operaciones decir gramos
se cancela con desi gramos
422% es 42.242 1200 y finalmente las
unidades nos quedan miligramos
miligramos va entonces ya nos quedó la
conversión 422 decigramos son 42 mil 200
miligramos y ya nada más para que para
practicar un poquito lo que hicimos
arriba déjame hacer eso mismo de pasar
primero a gramos y luego a miligramos
voy a bajar un poco para tener un poco
más de espacio entonces cómo le haríamos
déjame tomar este color amarillo también
podríamos hacer lo siguiente empezamos
con 422 decigramos de si gramos y ahora
vamos a pasar a gramos vamos a poner
arriba gramos y abajo decigramos de 100
gramos cuál es una unidad más pequeña
pues decigramos verdades y gramos es más
pequeño que gramos de esta forma tenemos
que dividir entre 10 el prefijo de si es
de 10 entonces para que nos quede menos
de 422 tenemos que dividir entre 10
entonces aquí nos quedaría decigramos se
va con decigramos 422 entre 1640 y 2.2
gramos muy bien y ahora lo que faltaría
es pasar a miligramos cómo le hacemos
vemos que es mili mil y tiene que ver
con 1000 pero ahora es una unidad más
pequeña así que tendremos que
multiplicar por mil por mil porque mil
miligramos son un gramo y con esto las
unidades ya que también gramos se
cancelar con gramos y 42.2 por 1000 es
42 1200 y de unidades nos queda
miligramos y entonces nos dio lo mismo
que la otra forma de resolver vale
entonces pues están muy fáciles estos
problemas de conversión lo más
importante es aprenderse los prefijos
para de ahí poder saber a qué número
corresponden y después simplemente vamos
verificando con la realidad si tenemos
que que tienen que ser más de esas
unidades o menos de esas unidades
dependiendo si pasamos a una unidad más
pequeña
más grande vale bueno creo que después
de ver estos ejemplos tú ya puedes
intentar algunos por tu cuenta así que
pues intenta los y diviértete mucho nos
vemos en los siguientes vídeos